bueno creo que ella ha dado muestras de
qué países se va a acercar cuando él ha
hecho referencia en varios discursos a
fortalecer las relaciones con los
principales socios comerciales como eeuu
la unión europea el ingreso a la alianza
del pacífico que acaba de decirlo
también en su en su discurso y por lo
tanto creo que va a digamos a volver a
una política más pragmática en términos
de relaciones internacionales
quisiera quisiera retomar algo que
señalaba vicente está este camino hacia
la normalidad como lo planteaba muy
acertadamente creo que va a ser muy
difícil para un gobierno como el de
guillermo lazo porque ese camino
requiere de la comprensión y el apoyo de
otros actores políticos y en lo que
hemos escuchado hasta este momento
ha hablado ha abordado los temas
económicos y sociales como debería ser
porque esas son las prioridades sin duda
pero todavía a mí me queda
el interés de ver qué es lo que va a
decir sobre el tema político propiamente
en ese sentido quisiera destacar que el
discurso de la presidenta de la asamblea
fue un discurso muy interesante un
discurso también de apertura y de
coincidencia de convergencia de las
fuerzas políticas viniendo esto de un
partido como pachakutik que es un
partido que no ha tenido
responsabilidades en el ámbito
institucional como las que tiene ahora
creo que eso es muy importante y eso va
a ser un factor fundamental para la
gobernabilidad y para justamente
en este camino hacia el centro como lo
denominaba vicente estos temas que usted
demos a la normalidad estos temas que
ustedes plantean de volverán a la
normalidad tomando una serie de medidas
como como el presidente evita tomar una
serie de medidas que puedan resultar
impopulares y generen por ejemplo otro
estallido social como el que ocurrió en
octubre de 2019
creo que esto va a obligar a hacer un
gobierno que busque siempre consensos
que busquen acuerdos él ha puesto mucho
énfasis en esto el encuentro que podría
también llamarse el acuerdo que por
cierto es interesante considerar que el
acuerdo es un anagrama de ecuador es
decir con las mismas letras se pueden
formar las dos palabras
y eso podría utilizarse como una digamos
una forma de impulsar un gran acuerdo
nacional por lo menos en el primero o
los dos primeros años de gobierno de
guillermo lasso que van a ser los más
difíciles sin ese acuerdo nacional va a
ser muy difícil y podríamos tener
problemas serios digamos como los que
está enfrentando colombia si es que se
pretende hacer un ajuste duro un ajuste
sin el componente político